I cannot believe you're not stepping
with us this year I've got to focus on
getting into Harvard there's a video
online the sigma theta beta member
having sex on their lawn
you need to make SBB look like positive
contributors to the community don't you
with a big charity step competition
coming up would you make this SBB mess
go away and I will guarantee you
admission to Harvard I think I have a
way to save your Charter and get you
reinstated do it compete in a charity
step show country lap dancer that
surprises no one stepping requires an
extraordinary amount of discipline we
don't drink during the scene enough
you're not teaching them are you Jam go
you crazy
if my sorors find out I teach a good
step is gonna get ugly
[Music]
they can't work together as a team or
screws the shading is real you guys
because you don't respect each other if
you build up the sisterhood I promise
you have a real shot I said hell yeah
your sisterhood is your bond do not let
it break you guys feeling out of place
but maybe they're judging you before
you've had a chance to express
yourselves you're in this position for
ten minutes you can drown in a pool
white girl tears well are you gonna
cowboy
I'm from Kappa next door you shook our
house we lost a row of totally
irreplaceable
[Music]